unsere show nummer eins nach der
winterpause und natürlich nach umwelt so
geht ja viele wissen das gar nicht aber
wir da bin ich stolz drauf haben ja seit
über zehn jahren immer ein kinderchor in
der deko stehen für alle fälle sind fünf
von mir persönlich öko statistisch
indoktrinierten böse gutmenschen kinder
die auf kommando senioren hass lieder
singen geht jetzt nicht mehr
es gibt zu viel ärger muss die alle
feuer naja guckt nicht so traurig kann
es nicht ändern
ihr seid raus hört doch auf ihr heuchler
bedankt euch alle beim doofen wdr5
arbeitslose kinder mehr
vielen dank tom buhrow
sid
satire hin oder her wenn es die leute zu
sehr ärgert tanzt es nicht machen klima
ist halt unser emotionales thema
klimawandel
das sieht man ja aktuell auch sehr schön
beim kohleausstieg ja sicher verfolgt
der plan für den kohleausstieg diese
woche im kabinett verabschiedet
das heißt als erstes land der welt
steigt deutschland aus atom und kohle
aus kuba wir haben einen ausstiegsplan
so jetzt die schlechte nachricht wir
haben leider keinen einstiegs plan
ich wünschte es wäre ein witz der ausbau
der windenergie ist quasi zum erliegen
gekommen
genauso wie die sache mit den
stromtrassen eine absolute
bankrotterklärung für die vergeigte
energiewende und für den
verantwortlichen minister hier ein wenn
sie sacken lassen unglaublicher satz
stellen sich mal eine sekunde vor wir
hätten alle diese aktivitäten schon vor
zehn jahren gestartet und es hätte vor
zehn jahren jemanden gegeben der gesagt
hätte wir müssen die stromnetze bauen
mit hochdruck jetzt aber sofort dann
werden die alles schon fertig ja
ja
ja genau das hätte ich mal jemand machen
sollen aber findet mal ein du willst ja
keine handwerker mehr das ist ja so und
wenn man wie altmaier hier gesetze macht
in denen fünf häuser als siedlung gelten
dann klickt man die windenergie
endgültig wie wenn man so bis 2030 bitte
die 65 prozent erneuerbare energien
schaffen gar nicht immerhin das ist die
einzig gute nachricht aus dieser woche
gibt es ein paar tolle neuigkeiten für
die freunde des hambacher festes
ich freue mich einsatz noch ich freue
mich dass eine klare entscheidung jetzt
zum hambacher forst haben da muss sie
selber lachen dies wäre ja ja da muss
sie selber lachen
es sind nämlich so aus der hambacher
forst bleibt tatsächlich quasi als
symbol allerdings haben sie drum herum
leider fast alles recht getan hat was
jetzt natürlich blöd ist für den einen
besitzer der da immer noch in seinem
bauernhaus wohl
ja die eltern vergessen dem sven ole
bescheid zu sagen würde sagen ja also
wirklich die bäume bleiben aber dafür
werden fünf dörfer in der region
umgesiedelt für die braunkohle merkel
du kannst bei uns ganze dörfer weg
baggern aber du kannst kein windrad mehr
daneben bauen und speziell im osten darf
die braunkohle auch viel länger
gefördert werden als von der kohle
kommission im letzten jahr gefordert
sachsen-anhalts ministerpräsident
haseloff tja sagt auch ganz offen und
ehrlich warum weil bei ihm sagt er sonst
zu viele leute afd wählen ja und diese
leute diesen nervösen leute muss man
beruhigen
die muss man den ganzen tag beruhigen ja
nicht schuldig es ist ja so der ganze
kohle ausstiegsplan der groko der stinkt
förmlich nach angst vor der afd
wie kann man einer partei indirekt so
viel macht geben die den
menschengemachten klimawandel immer noch
stumpf leuten im gegen alle
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse und
deren schlaueste köpfe sowas hier
erzählen man sollte mal darüber
nachdenken ob die temperatur der ozeane
möglicherweise was mit der temperatur
der sonne oder mit der mit der aktivität
der sonne zusammenhängt wenn die sonne
besonders heißes dann mag das ja auch
einen einfluss auf die wassertemperatur
immer wieder senken
der evergreen beatrix von storch immer
noch die geistige energiesparlampe der
afd
statt solchen leuten argumentativ
entgegen zu treten was ja eigentlich
einfache ist kusch die groko mit ihrem
aufgeweichten kohle plan vor
potenziellen fdp wählern die kuschen vor
potenziellen ft will ich sage ihnen wenn
das im alltag schule macht dann aber
gute nacht 2,8 promille
und da ist nicht einfach weiterfuhr
schloss sich nämlich af die ach so macht
dann gute fahrt fall war kurz
[Applaus]
das auf die milch muss im aufrechten
da steht ja es ist wirklich traurig
wirklich traurig was frau merkel
mit diesen vier ministerpräsidenten im
hinterzimmer außerdem an sich schönen
kohlekompromiss gemacht hat bestes
beispiel haben sie wahrscheinlich auch
gelesen datteln 4
was ist das denn bitte für ein signal
diesen sommer ein neues
steinkohlekraftwerk ans netz gehen zu
lassen kohleausstieg neues kraftwerk
merken sie auch ne das macht alles
keinen sinn mehr das problem auch die
steinkohle compassion von sehr weit her
zum teil aus russland oder kolumbien
super das macht total sind ja ja und das
ist ja noch nicht alles freunde für
datteln 4 kein witz wird sogar kohle aus
australien hierüber gekarrt aus
australien
ja als werden die koalas nicht schon
genug gestraft wirklich dieser
sogenannte kohle plan ist ineffizient
und viel zu teuer meint ich finde es
wichtig dass die betroffenen regionen 40
milliarden strukturhilfe kriegen wenn
die kohle mal irgendwann weg ist aber
was wird dann mit dem geld konkret
gemacht mit diesen 40 milliarden
das weiß noch keiner gutes werden wohl
ein zwei neue forschungs einrichtungen
gebaut im osten forschungseinrichtungen
warum nicht
ob man an so einem arbeitsplatz jetzt
als ehemaliger kumpel sich so einfach
integrieren kann weiß es nicht
wird schwierig würde echt schwierig und
man ganz ohne ironie wie schön meint es
ehrlich wie schön für die 2000 kumpel
wie zum beispiel in schkopau
sachsen-anhalt doch bis 2034 weiter
kohle ausbuddeln
aber warum redet keiner über die
zehntausende jobs die zuletzt in der
wind und sonnenenergie weggefallen sind
da redet keiner drüber die haben keine
lobby
wer würde schon lieder hören wie glück
auf der photovoltaik anlagen
mechatroniker komme ich nicht
so 4,3 milliarden entschädigung kriegen
alleine die kohle kraftwerksbetreiber
wohlgemerkt für wirklich uralter teile
die demnächst sowieso unrentabel werden
geld für alten schrott wo gibt's denn so
was natürlich in ihrem zdf herzlich
willkommen zu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
joho zuschauer was sagt juesy l für
nutzlos und alten
der deutsche starb oder wie ich ihn
nenne
der dümmste händler der welt heutige
vertretung durch die chefin selber als
last und in der rolle des völlig
verblödeten steuerzahlers dolly
ja
das läuft wie geschnitten brot
frau merkel hat eben für ihr neues
digital ministerium 3000 von diesen
hightech geräten gebaut eine völlig neue
kombination aus telefon und fax das
heißt man kann sich seine e mails
ausdrucken und wie dankbar fax
verschickt
so und jetzt kommt ein weiterer trödel
vorziehen
er sitzt im vorstand der firma rwg dann
ist wohl ein kleiner mittelständischer
familienbetrieb der sich auf antike
kohlekraftwerke spezialisiert und
wunderbare andere schätzchen die jetzt
leider vom netz müssen und dafür will
das gehe natürlich gerne sehr gerade zum
beispiel fürs kraftwerk weisweiler
das enthält anlagen aus dem jahr 1959
859 ja damals sah unsere kanzlerin noch
so aus
die polizei
viele noch mal
und klavier war in den charts ganz beim
gipfel der wunderbaren peter kraus
übrigens heute in einem besseren zustand
als die kraftwerke von rw ja ganz genau
die dinger sind seit zig jahren
abgeschrieben damit hat sich rwe hier
mehrere goldene ärsche verdienten kein
normaler mensch würde dafür ein völlig
normaler mensch sicher nicht aber die
groko schon maßen 2 6 milliarden
[Applaus]
so muss man erst mal sein wunderbar hier
basiert auf ich habe überhaupt nichts
gekauft die hat das gekauft ist denn
hier los ich bezahle stromerzeuger weil
sie keinen strom erzeugen
ich will auch mal geld für nix sarah
kreieren wie noch nie wir sind doch
mainz wo den hammer hier ein schmieriger
vorstand der firma lear die stehen 5000
megawatt braunkohlestrom legendären
dreckschleudern wie der schwarze pumpe
oder boxberg in der lausitz wenn alle
ausgeknipst
auch j schon jetzt guckt da ganz traurig
schauen sie mal in dieser manager augen
und sagen sind dem der krieg nix ja ich
sage ihm das sehr gerne
jetzt reicht sie mich das habe ich im
spiegel gelesen freunde die lehre will
geld frau merkel obwohl die ihre
kohlegruben gar nicht früher schließen
als sie es ohnehin selber geplant hatten
enttäuschend sind vielleicht blöd habe
ich sag mal so blöd auch ne frau merkel
wirklich
ich liebe
[Applaus]
mir doch einmal einen stoffen braunkohle
und nächste woche vor allem uns beim bau
des genres auf einen extrem
zwielichtigen händler namens aldi ist
der wäre davon merke ein neues konzept
verkaufen das nennt sich pkw-maut klingt
interessant
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye